shocking Silence from the biggest
women's groups in the country as the
squad reaches a disgusting new low in
their defense of Hamas Progressive
congresswoman prila jaipal downplaying
the numerous and well-documented rapes
of Israeli women by the
terrorists I've condemned what Hamas has
done I've condemned all of the actions
absolutely the the rape the of course
but I think we have to remember that
Israel is a democracy see that is why
they are a strong Ally of ours I'm
asking you about Hamas in fact I already
answered your question Dana I I said
it's horrific and I think that rape is
horrific sexual assault is horrific I
think that it happens in war situations
terrorist organizations like Hamas
obviously are using these as tools
however I think we have to be balanced
about bringing in the outrages against
Palestinians but you you don't see
Israeli soldiers raping um well Dana I
think we're not we're not I I don't want
this to be the hierarchy of oppressions
oh yeah you do so jaul thinks we need to
be balanced when talking about
atrocities like this an October 7th
Survivor says he witnessed as many as 10
Hamas terrorists brutally assaulting and
gang raping an Israeli woman the victim
who screamed out to be killed was then
tragically shot in the head and where
are the women's groups we've reached out
to some of the top female advocacy
organizations in the country that
support liberal causes and ask them if
they condemn her so far
crickets Dana um and the White House
could barely condemn the squad
watch was that an appropriate comment
what Hamas did is absolutely
reprehensible and full stop rape and the
use of rape as being used as a as a
weapon uh that is also reprehensible and
that's full stop and I'll just leave it
there and speaking for the president of
the United States I think they' been
very clear on that any comment though
Congressman G I just commented on it I
just laid out what we believe is
unacceptable oh say Dana from a
Communications perspective when you
say gang rapes you probably don't want
to say the word but or however
afterwards just stop like as Karen
jeanpierre said full stop I wonder if
the White House ever gets tired of
having to figure out a way to not offend
the squad but defend themselves in in
this situation I found this very
discouraging I knew anti-Semitism
existed I just didn't know that it
didn't ex that the that it would extend
so much to specifically to Israeli women
as if they don't matter at all and when
she says you mentioned it too I wrote it
down that um when when jaul says I don't
want to get into the hierarchy of
Oppression like yes you do that's what
we have to do every day because that's
what you guys bring up
constantly and this isn't like it's
October 8th and we're wondering if there
were rapes we absolutely know that news
has been there and she has access to
information I guess either she chooses
not to see it or maybe she hasn't heard
from the state department the state
department has said today confirmed
something that the IDF said over the
weekend that Hamas may not release any
more of the prisoners especially the
women why because they don't want it to
be known what happened to them in
captivity so I can only assume there's
been more mass rape and violence against
women she says that this is not an easy
question this is actually the easiest
question I've ever heard the other thing
I would just end with is all those
women's groups that you put up there
over and over again we see the same
pattern they marched in lock step in
their condemnation of all sorts of
people in the me tooo movement right
believe all women these are the same
groups though who if you go back to the
late 1990s they all walked away from
defending Monica Lewinsky they all will
turn a blind eye to something if they
think that it will help their political
position or it will protect them from
condemnation by somebody like jaipal if
I were there I would be thrilled to be
condemned by jaipal it would be an honor
are you shocked that these women's
groups didn't even get back to our
producers judge yeah I am shocked
because for the longest time I mean you
know I was part of that original
movement which you know was fighting for
rape victims making sure that rape
victims didn't have to take a lie
detector test making sure that a defense
attorney could not say to the jury well
she was dressed that way she deserved it
I mean I was there in the beginning but
then all of a sudden about 10 years ago
we have this me too movement as though
they just discovered you know the abuse
and the suppression of women but but but
this new Progressive so-called
Progressive group is really a regressive
one they they are taking back the
Decades of of progress that we've made
fighting for women's rights fighting to
make sure that women are not suppressed
or oppressed by this what what clearly
is a war crime but this is how it's
being looked at Greg describes it as the
oppressor and the oppressed I see it as
their ideology their politics pretty
much dictates their belief system and
that prioritizes everything for them so
that it clouds the truth it clouds right
and wrong we know that there were rapes
we know their pelvises were broken we
know that their bodies tell us in death
what happened to them in life but what
they are saying is that whether or not
you're oppressed depends upon what group
you belong to and if we believe that uh
you are not part of our tribe our
ideology or our group then you are not
oppressed and I'll tell you aside from
all these women's groups aside from the
UN and it's silence I mean I have no use
for them anyway I think they do nothing
but crowd traffic in New York the woman
that stuns me is Michelle Obama hashtag
bring our girls home where is she now
where is she now that we know that the
women who are now prisoners and hostages
you think they're having lunch and tea
every day I don't think so and finally
um these women are destroying other
women and the hardle activism is
destroying women's rights in this
country Harold Jun so I think Cheryl
sber first of all it's good to be back
around the table everybody had a good
weekend um Cheryl Sandberg I think said
it really well capsize a lot of it she
said this talking about how the world is
looking at this and responding to the
fact that some of the groups that you
put up on the screen that Dana and the
judge have talked about have not
responded forcefully she said this goes
beyond politics I'm going to paraphrase
this goes beyond politics if we can't
agree that rape is wrong what is
happening to our our Humanity um I think
it it it diminishes and and makes it
harder to take credibly the argument of
pro Palestinian activists when uh who I
think argue for two-state Solution
that's an honorable outcome and should
be something we all aim for but you
can't argue that and expect people to
listen to you if you first can't say
release the hostages and two the actions
of Hamas and Israel on October the 7th
as Greg uh consistently points out um U
was horrendous was inhumane and that at
no no time there's no moment where you
should ever be able to you ever use the
word rape and say but however but let me
say this um this is just wrong and it's
unfortunate uh that we can't get to a
more reasonable and sensible and
long-term conversation because those who
are advocating on behalf of the
Palestinians at least some in our own
country are doing it in such a horrible
and counterproductive and I'll use the
word that my friend cherl Sandberg used
an inhumane way m mhm Greg there was a
lot of discussion about you don't want
to conflate the Palestinians with Hamas
okay but it would help if the
Palestinians and their supporters like
her would condemn Hamas yeah their
silence is conflating themselves with
Hamas it's it is it's amazing when you
consider the meoo movement in in that
context we went from believe all women
to believe no women if they're Jewish
right and you it's not about like where
are the women's groups it's like who do
the women's groups represent who do they
represent now we know they don't
represent any Republican women or
libertarian women or pro-life women or
Independent Women among feminists they
don't represent women in sports who
don't want to compete against men they
don't uh they don't uh represent women
who believe in legitimate safe spaces
away from men right they don't represent
obviously Jewish women and they don't
represent white women unless they buy a
dinner where they confess that they're
an oppressor to uh uh woke Scholars and
I'm trying to think who's left to
represent is it men who say they're
women because once you no longer stand
up for victims of mass rape what good
are you as a woman's group right you're
you're worthless you're pathetic I think
we need to reframe this because we've
been too e easy on these idiots we've
given them a free ride by describing
October 7th as an act of Terror because
we know the kneejerk response when you
call somebody a terrorist they always
say one man's terrorist is another man's
freedom fighter and then you start
talking about the historical context
well there is no historical context for
sexual atrocity that is the word that's
the phrase that needs to be employed
from now on on October 7th it was a
sexual atrocity because then you don't
leave any wiggle room to these
misogynous monsters out there it the
label is 100% true and it it it and the
the evidence is there as as opposed to
something like Kavanaugh where one
allegation recent allegation decades ago
no evidence no evidence and that was an
Abomination and yet you have a mountain
of dreadful evidence and they don't do
it so every moment you spend on behalf
of the perpetrators makes you an
apologist for the world's only planned
sexual atrocity in modern history when
you come face to face with these
protesters or you have them on a TV show
you have to ask them how can you accept
sexual atrocity if they deny it then
they should be called sexual atrocity
deniers and that should stick with them
for the rest of of their lives because
if I think what happened was we allowed
an out on this we kind of moved away
from this when we should have just said
wait a second this is like like the UN
waited what a month two months and it's
because we didn't call it what it was we
just just kept saying Act of Terror and
I think if you just put that label on it
uh they can't right now we have misogyny
harnessed by Marxism to carve out power
for these people that's all it is that's
why they don't care they didn't care
about Monica Linsky they they and then
they cared about Brett Kavanaugh and now
they don't care about this it makes you
wonder like you know this is
orchestrated but it's also deeply
emotional what whole is this filling for
all of these unhappy women they're all
in cities there so there's so many young
women willing to align themselves to a
movement that denies sexual atrocity
what is that energy shift coming from
why are they doing this I don't think
it's making them any happier is it
because a society of leisure made it so
that they can migrate to extreme beliefs
because all the other beliefs are taken
I don't know how many moms are okay with
this I don't think there are any no
there's definitely something missing in
their lives that's for sure sexual
atrocity that is is a powerful word hi
everyone I'm Brian kilme I want you to
do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now